john dark lives in beirut and is one of
millions suffering during lebanon's
water crisis if she didn't pay for
supplies from private companies her taps
would run dry water has been in short
supply for decades but the situation is
now
critical
not enough is being purified and pumped
due to electricity blackouts caused by
fuel shortages the state is nearly
bankrupt so is much of the population
not being it used to cost 90 000 lira
now it costs 700 000 lira to have water
delivered twice a week some of our
neighbors can afford it so we cover them
ask the government what it's doing the
situation has become unbearable we don't
even have electricity
private supplies are too expensive for
most at least 70 percent of the
population could run out of water in the
coming weeks
like hospitals and businesses we are
unable to get hold of fuel easily
maintenance costs are also high so we
are forced to increase our water prices
we get about 90 calls a day from those
needing water but we can only respond to
about 10 we are providing a service that
the government isn't and should be doing
unicef warns the sanitation system could
seize all together if millions of
dollars aren't invested the
cash-strapped government can't afford to
import chemicals needed to keep water
clean
we have been supporting the water
establishment for their maintenance for
the past year
but it has come to the point that our
support is
not even enough so therefore we started
really alarming international community
to really get going more direct support
the water is the life of people
if we don't act now these 2.5 people
number can rise even up to four million
the inadequate water infrastructure is
widely blamed on decades of corruption
and mismanagement of funds and
increasing land development and water
pollution is making it much
worse lebanon's tap water is so toxic
you can't even drink it and the
infrastructure to deliver that is at
breaking point now it absolutely smells
here and that's because natural sources
of water like this one are so polluted
that water-borne diseases are common
especially among children
aid agencies warn that vulnerable
communities including hundreds of
thousands of syrian and palestinian
refugees in lebanon are most at risk
water is already being rationed in the
worst affected areas once that runs out
most people are likely to go thirsty
al jazeera beirut